hallo schön Dich zu sehen ich bin nicht
wirklich echt aber das wusstest Du
vermutlich schon vermutlich aber gibt es
inzwischen so viele von mir weil es
chatgpt gibt und seit einem Jahr das
Thema künstliche Intelligenz groß
diskutiert wird auch ich wurde von einer
Computersoftware erschaffen bin ich
deswegen schon
intelligent
ch GPT hat im vergangenen Jahr die
Entwicklung in vielen itbereichen
beschleunigt aber hat das textool auch
die Welt auf den Kopf gestellt z.B die
Schulwelt okay gewisslich auch wenn der
Sturm der Verfolgung sich erhebt wird
mein Glaube wie ein Fels im mitten des
Meeres
stehen seine Worte sind mein Trost und
sein Licht erhält meinen Pfad inmitten
der Dunkelheit mag der Feind brüllen und
mich umringen mein Vertrauen allein auf
dem Herrn der mich errettet und mich
stark macht also wenn ich jetzt nicht
wüsste dass das KI ist würd es mich
berühren das ist ja die Frage die mich
so ein bisschen die mich so ein bisschen
umtreibt kann eine künstliche
Intelligenz mich sogar emotional
berühren ich glaub das Problem ist wenn
man halt eben nicht weiß dass eben KI
ist sind Worte verwandt die natürlich
Emotionen in einem hervorrufen können
gerade angesichts der Frage ne der
Verfolgung ja das heißt es sind die
richtigen Worte gewählt die Frage ist
halt
nur wie gut kann man das in einen
Kontext oder kann man das in einem
Kontext sehen was dort was dort
aneinander Bibelverse aus dem Tablet
angesichts des gigantischen Potenzial
eine eher kleine Anwendung aber mit
weitreichenden Folgen das kann ich schon
verstehen dass wir eine Beschleunigung
haben die dazu führt dass die
Schülerinnen und Schüler eigentlich gar
nicht drum rumkommen sich solche
Hilfsmittel zu nehmen aber wünschen tue
ich es mir nicht ich wünsche mir
eigentlich dass wir uns die Zeit nehmen
Schule heißt ursprünglich mße also Zeit
sich wirklich mit den Dingen auseinander
zu setzen und das wird durch chch BT
glaube ich nicht leichter an dieser
Hamburger Schule sind Tablets ab der
achten Klasse Teil des Unterrichtes
vielleicht steht Chat GPT auch deshalb
nicht mehr so hoch im Kurs alle hier
lernen gründlich im Netz zu suchen wenn
ich das benutze benutze ich das eher um
zu recherchieren alsoag um das Thema um
was es geht zu verstehen ähm und
sozusagen dann die Aufgabe selber besser
beantworten zu können also ich benutze
eher so statt Google benutze ich Hal um
als recherchemittel zum Verständnis
eines Themas zu benutzen also schreib
manchmal echt komisch
deswegen such ich einfach ganz normal
mir das gesag schon selber zusammen ich
mag gerne sozusagen selbst für meine
Arbeit verantwortlich zu sein also
selbst am Ende soag die Kontrolle über
alles zu haben und da ist es einfach
nicht so relevant für mich am Anfang
hatten sie versucht das intelligente
chattool auch für kreative schreibzwecke
einzusetzen inzwischen aber können die
Lehrer ganz gut einschätzen was kann die
Schülerin oder der Schüler wirklich und
wo hat vielleicht KI
geholfen die Schüler können sehr schnell
mit wenig Aufwand ein fertiges Produkt
abgeben und das ist aber nicht lernen
wir wollen ja nicht schnell fertig
werden sondern wir wollen versuchen die
Schüler in ja in eigenes Denken in
eigenes urteilen in verstehen in
Prozesse hinein zu bringen
eine Frage reinzugeben den Text zu haben
und dann irgendwie abzugeben das ist ich
habe mit wenig Aufwand meine
Hausaufgaben gemacht das ist wie
Fastfood und ich glaube das ist der
Punkt wo wir an Schule noch nicht fertig
sind der Reiz des Neuen ist weg aber
bewusst das als
Arbeitsinstrument Arbeit unterstrichen
und nicht Instrument das als
Arbeitsinstrument zu nutzen da müssen
wir die Schüler hin erziehen weil die
Bequemlichkeit ja quem sind wir alle und
schnell ein Ergebnis zu haben hat seinen
Reiz aber hilft uns
nicht einen ersten Überblick zu einem
Thema eine To-Do Liste bei neuen
Aufgaben Backrezepte Märchen erzählen
das texttool hat auf nahe zuu alle
Fragen plausible Antworten aber ist das
schon Intelligenz zumindest hat Chat GPT
diese Frage
aufgeworfen ich glaube es hat die
Beschäftigung mit dem Thema künstliche
Intelligenz in den Vordergrund üt weil
viele Leute zwar schon die ganze Zeit KI
verwenden das aber nicht als künstliche
Intelligenz verstehen wenn Sie Ihr Handy
entsperren wenn sie Suchmaschinen
verwenden wenn Sie empfehlungssoftware
verwenden das ist auch alles KI aber es
hat eben nicht diesen Charakter dass man
mit einer Software interagiert mit einer
Art chatboard was eher den Eindruck
erweckt dass der etwas denkt und
intelligent ist aber die Grundlage von
allen Systemen ist tatsächlich reine
Statistik und das muss man sich klar
machen dass ist sowohl bei diesen
Chatbots und chatgpt der Fall als auch
bei Suchmaschinen und anderen Verfahren
es war einmal eine Katze die hieß Minka
war sehr schlau und schnell aber sie
hatte auch Angst vor vielen Dingen vor
allem vor Wölfen eines Tages begegnet
ein Märchen eine ausgedachte Geschichte
nur auf den ersten Blick jedem Wort gibt
das Tool eine Wahrscheinlichkeit die
Wahrscheinlichkeit welches Wort als
nächstes kommt System ist trainiert
worden darauf diesen Dialog aufrecht zu
erhalten und dabei wird häufig verkannt
dass das System eben auch halluziniert
das heißt anfängt einfach zu fantasieren
und Dinge zu erfinden Dinge in den
Kontext zu stellen die eigentlich gar
nicht zusammengehören aber andere
machine learning Modelle könnten ja auch
auf Wahrheit auf Korrektheit trainiert
sein und plötzlich würden aus solchen
Werkzeugen ganz mächtige Instrumente
werden nicht nur in der Wissenschaft
also die Risiken die dadurch entstehen
können sind schon enorm und wenn man
allein heute schon sieht dass etwa
Informationskampagnen mit jatgpt
unterstützt werden werden können und
eben dann auch für missinformation
genutzt werden dann sehen wir die
Risiken im Grunde jetzt
schon Text ist dabei nur der Anfang
bilderzeugende Tools wie midjourney
stable Diffusion Deli oder Firefly sind
längst keine Anwendungen mehr für
Spezialisten solche zeitreisen sind
dabei noch
Kunst gefälschte Bilder mehr oder
weniger gut gerechnet sind auch nur ein
paar Eingaben weit entfernt dieses kann
wohl jeder als Fälschung entlafen
aufwendig erstellte deep Fakes dagegen
sind nur schwer zu
erkennen ich habe nicht wirklich Angst
wieder vor der Entwicklung der Technik
sondern was wir gemerkt haben ist dass
kleine Entscheidungen von wenigen
wichtigen Akteuren oder oder mächtigen
Akteuren große Auswirkungen haben können
es war eine Entscheidung von Open ai
Chat GPT eine Technologie die es schon
länger gab frei verfügbar auf den Markt
zu werfen mit einem einfachen Interface
so dass es alle verwenden konnten und
dadurch dass es so einfach und breit
nutzbar war hat es auf einmal massive
Auswirkungen gehabt das heißt es sind
manchmal einfach Entscheidungen von
Menschen die große Auswirkungen haben
die wir vielleicht nicht so schnell
abschätzen können und das macht so
Prognosen in die Zukunft teilweise sehr
sehr schwer open ai heißt die
Entwicklerfirma von GPT das steht für
generative pretrained Transformer also
eine auf schnelle textantworten
trainierte
Software mit Erfinder Sam suchte
pünktlich zum einjährigen von chatgbt
Streit mit dem Aufsichtsrat er würde die
Zukunft der KI Anwendung nicht genügend
erklären so der Vorwurf dabei ist die
Frage was darf KI wohl die wichtigste in
der derzeitigen
Entwicklung wir haben im Moment einige
Initiativen gesetzesebenen die unterwegs
sind die auch noch erst in Kraft treten
müssen dementsprechend braucht es
natürlich noch mehr Regulierung oder
gute Regulierung die bestimmte Gefahren
tatsächlich versucht auch zu verhindern
man muss sich klar machen die KI die
Systeme machen Statistik und
mustererkennungen deswegen können die
für sehr viel Gutes eingesetzt werden im
medizinischen Bereich aber auch
meinwegen im Bereich von
Energieeffizienz oder ähnlichen Sachen
und auf der anderen Seite können sie
eben sehr viel Schaden einrichten und da
muss man eben genau hingucken deswegen
habe ich auf der einen Seite sehr
neutralen Blick auf die Technik aber
nicht so neutralen Blick auf die
Verwendungsweisen Bilder mit
pornografischen oder
gewaltverherrlichenden Inhalten Fake
News gefälschte Internetseiten
Desinformationskampagnen all das kann
Chat GPT erzeugen manches weißt der
ethische Filter ab manches erkennt auch
die Prüfsoftware nicht das
unkontrollierbare Wachstum von
kianwendungen macht selbstvertreter so
mancher itunternehmen nervös die
Entwicklung sei so ein offener Brief
vergleichbar mit einer Pandemie oder dem
Atomkrieg wir haben also die Problematik
dass Dinge dual use sind oder eben auch
für Zwecke eingesetzt werden für die sie
ursprünglich nicht gedacht waren und in
der Hand von Menschen werden solche
Instrumente natürlich auch eingesetzt um
damit Schaden anzurichten wenn man eben
sieht dass damit natürlich auch Geräte
trainiert werden können bishin eben auch
zu drohen und ähnlichem die dann ihre
Ziele alleine suchen dann macht mir das
wirklich ernsthaft Sorgen und es braucht
selbstverständlich auch hier
völkerrechtliche Abkommen und man könnte
sich durchaus vorstellen dass im Laufe
sozusagen eines Diskurses auch das ein
Ergebnis sein könnte KI atz im Bereich
autonomer Systeme im militärischen
Bereich ist
geächtet dabei haben die meisten
Forscher eigentlich nur so etwas im Sinn
Hilfssysteme die Menschen unterstützen
und Arbeit abnehmen Chat GPT hilft auch
wenn die Frage stimmt ch TPT der lernt
Halil von Daten dann antwortet der halt
auf deine Fragen aber du weißt
eigentlich nicht wie sollte die Antwort
gibt also z.B manchmal ist es falsch
manchmal ist es richtig aber das ist
überhaupt keine Möglichkeit eigentlich
jetzt zu wissen wieso ist es falsch
wieso ist es richtig und eine
Möglichkeit ist die wir uns überlegen
dass man jetzt guckt welcher Text
eigentlich dazu beigetragen hat dass er
diese Antwort
gibt auch andere kitools wie Bart Siri
Alexa haben dieses Problem die
Anwendungen mit allem zu trainieren was
das Internet hergibt reproduziert die
gleichen falschen Daten die auch im Netz
zu finden sind Folgefehler sozusagen die
die KI als richtig interpretiert das
Rezept der Forscher gezieltes Training
für sehr spezifische
Aufgaben der Roboter der in der Küche
eingesetzt lernt von den Kochvideos aber
die Idee ist natürlich dass das das die
wirkliche Intelligenz ist es ist wieder
Mensch der hat nicht ein videosatz und
lernt davon sondern der lernt über die
Zeit wie das gemacht wird und kann dann
auch wenn ein autoreparieren kann auch
ein rasenmähr reparieren oder solche
Sachen und das muss die kid nächste
Stufe von der KI dass der die KI auch
irgendwie in Allgemeinwissen hat und
dann direkt Sachen lösen kann ohne die
Daten vorher gesehen zu haben das führt
unweigerlich zu noch mehr
Eigenständigkeit der Anwendungen daher
kommt auch die richtige Bezeichnung für
KI maschinelles Lernen ob die Maschinen
dann irgendwann voneinander lernen ist
noch eine Frage von Science Fiction ich
denke mir mal das ist nicht gefährlich
ich meine man weiß ja genau was der
Roboter macht es ist ja von Menschen
programmiert wenn man das gut ma macht
besteht da überhaupt keine Gefahr in der
Gesellschaft gibt's viele Sachen die
nicht klar sind ich meine der Begriff KI
ist ja so Waage dass man eigentlich
damit gar nichts anfangen kann und Leute
haben dann Angst haben dann irgendwelche
Vorstellungen die nicht stimmen und
wissen eigentlich gar nicht was da jetzt
wirklich passiert was ja auch normal ist
was ich z gesagt habe dass man jetzt
auch von vielen medizinischen datenschen
lernen kann das wissen die meisten Leute
nicht weil sie ja die Techniken gar
nicht kennen und da muss man natürlich
schon aufklären und den Leuten erklären
was damit eigentlich gemacht werden kann
und wie man die Sachen verwenden kann
Chat GPT ist leicht zu verwenden die
Frage nach dem eigenen Geburtstag
beantwortet das Tool gewohnt souverän
aber eben auch leicht Hölzern von uns
gibt es als Geschenk die bildkii zum
Vorlesen dazu wenn Menschen meinen
Geburtstag feiern möchten könnten Sie
vielleicht den Tag meiner Einführung
oder in Betrieb als Anlass nehmen
natürlich bin ich jedoch nicht wirklich
in der Lage Feierlichkeiten oder
Ereignisse zu erleben wer weiß
vielleicht ändert sich das irgendwann in
nah Zukunft aber wohl eher
nicht